so I know I said I wasn't gonna die
anymore in TV shows but I need you to
find my episode Wednesday nice nice
yeah looks like I'm dying again do you
guys want to see how fast I was running
through that cornfield that's let's take
a look at that anyway this episode is
airing on November 3rd on CBS they shot
a bunch of behind the scenes videos
while I was there and you can check
those out
here right here you can just click on
one of those and be sure to come back
here after you guys watch the episode
and let me know what you thought of it
they also made a t-shirt that says I
love dead chicks with my creepy face on
it so if you would like to check that
out oh yeah right there
you can get it I just denotes Richard
calm not watch these other videos